Welcome back everyone, it's Charlie
This'll be my Full
Rick and Morty
Season 7 Episode 7 Video
There were a whole bunch of Easter Eggs and references
Also, I am sure they're going to turn that Kuato
Morty with the spider mech
into a radio controlled toy
or some kind of toy Kuatos for everyone.
So if you're brand new to the channel,
be sure to subscribe to get all the episodes.
And careful for spoilers
if you have not seen the episode yet,
we'll just start at the beginning, work
our way through shop.
John Talking about Easter eggs, WTF moments
all the Kuato jokes.
the episode title Wet
Kuat Mort Summer is a reference to the movie
Wet Hot American Summer
and the Total Recall movie with all the Kuato stuff.
The episode is mostly a Morty and summer Team-Up
episode with not a lot of Rick helping them out outside
of setting up the basic premise and then showing up
at the end of the episode to rescue them.
Wet Hot American Summer
didn't really have any kind of overarching plot
or anything like that other than being a slice of life
about the crazy summer.
A bunch of kids had a camp, so the episode is largely
just a total recall parody of all the Kuato stuff
Kuatos Within Kuatos within Kuatos
it's also the very first episode in the entire series
that uses Somer's name in the episode to handle
all the other family members have had their names
in episode titles before The Cold Open starts
with a bit about summer doing chores
for Rick from the tour wheel, just cleaning off
a bunch of alien blood and guts from his spaceship,
making it seem like this is taking place
right after he returned from another adventure
That happened between episode six and Episode
seven last week.
At the end of the episode, they also joked about them
going back on regular adventures again.
So presumably they've had a couple since then
In summer, doing
chores from Rick's Chore
Wheel is also a running thing with her.
This is meant to be different from the other wheel
that Rick has that they introduced in previous seasons,
which had Jerri's name on it.
It's like the entire family spins
that wheel and uses it a way to pick adventures.
Summers, chore wheel,
which it also sounds like Morty uses sometimes,
is like her version of Morty's
free adventure punch cards.
Basically, Rick making her do
chores is work in exchange for him
doing things for her or making things for her
whenever she wants the way that she talks about it,
it makes it seem like she's been using that
or they've been using that chore wheel for a long time.
She sorts a bunch of amulets for him,
some of them being magical ones with special powers
and curses, some of them being regular ones.
She even has a magical book
that Rick gave her to deal with any of the curses.
If it wasn't clear.
Even though Rick and Morty mostly deals
with science based stuff in scientific explanations
for more cosmic stuff
like explaining gods in scientific ways,
actual magic does exist in the Rick and Morty Universe
as do different planes of existence.
like there is an actual devil which they introduced
during season one in an actual God.
On the other side of that,
just based on the background here.
It seems like she's doing this on the first basement
level in the garage, like right below the garage.
she chops up a random alien in the backyard.
Not sure where it came from
or what Rick plans to do with all the alien parts,
her cleaning up the Morty's mind blowers room
with a bunch of the broken bottles
is a reference to them having another Morty's
mind blowers adventure before this
that we just didn't see at some point
in the fact that everything's broken in here
implies that the exact same thing happened,
like the adventure led to the same result
with them fighting each other,
breaking a bunch of the memories.
I think they also reference this at the end of the last
Morty's mind blowers episode like it happens
all the time and it always ends with one of them or
both of them trying to kill each other or themselves.
Rick references
having just upgraded Somer's ponytail,
giving it some inspector gadget powers
which they pay off later in the episode,
like Morty's body turning into things.
Rick does that too.
He's got all these Inspector Gadget parts,
which they also use later in the episode.
it makes sense that summer would get some of those
do he's also created ghost
goggles for her that he said
he put in the vending machine so she can see ghosts.
There have been a lot of ghost references this season
in particular, like first Rick creating actual ghosts
then people turning into ghosts and now people doing
more Ghostbuster like stuff, just seeing them.
She gets them to make the attributes lighter,
which is based on the core role playing game stats,
which is why when she wants to raise one stat,
another stat has to be balanced to decrease
because she has a fixed number of total attribute
points.
they said that the whole bit about the Frisbee Golf
Party calling it froth, apparently
it's like the most popular thing you could possibly do
at their high school outside of, like, football
most of my experience with Frisbee based sports
or actually ultimate Frisbee,
which is more of like a college sport,
which is where I learned to play it for the most part.
my experience with it was more like Brad's in that
I had a regular main sport
and just played Ultimate Frisbee
out of the regular season like I was an NCAA swimmer
Frisbee golf is basically
just like an extension of Ultimate Frisbee.
But it is a real sport that people play.
They pay off.
Another scene from the intro when she lifts him, going
full trophy jock versus nerd on him.
This is the second intro scene we've seen this season.
Rick provides more context on how the slider works
to saying that she's raised her strength
and lowered her intellect
so much that when he says he'll kill her,
she doesn't understand him more
he gets jealous wanting the stats slider to
so that he can impress Tricia and she'll make him seem
better in front of the whole school
so he'll get way more popular claiming
that he's already helped Rick a bunch.
He references helping him
kill Prime Rick during episode five which summer.
Then also comments on
Rick uses another new device which causes him to vanish
so he doesn't have to continue the conversation,
but it only sends him to the trash bag.
then part of the joke here is that Jimmy,
the rest of the school are hard core Frisbee golf fans.
Like they don't stop talking about
froth during the entire episode.
Every time you see them, it's all about froth.
all the posters, all the party favors, even the cake.
All the signs around
the house are references to Frisbee golf.
they've even got a special Star Wars parody poster
that says May the course be with you in a banner
that says the same thing In the backyard,
there's a banner that says Ultimate Snacks
was just a reference to Ultimate Frisbee.
maybe the writers of the episode
are just really big fans of Ultimate Frisbee.
some or uses the stat slider to almost hook up with
Jimmy till Morty tries to cock blocker.
notice in the backyard.
One of summers best friends
or maybe former best friends.
Nancy is there along with Tricia,
who's also one of her best friends.
It's a party
that Morty is trying to use to get more popular.
he turns her into like, way up, giving her
the oversize brains sticking out of her skull
a little bit in Morty, giving himself
abs is also something that they did during the Night
family episode in a previous season.
their couple jokes about them
using their different attributes against each other
with her making the trick shot against him.
Also, the equations here is something that they did
when they visualized powers during that superhero
family TV show
where the kid basically had the exact same ability
and they would visualize his powers the exact same way,
when summer takes him down with the crazy trick shot,
Jimmy says, This is what froth is all about,
because literally it's a game all about trick shots.
then their powers cause their genes to combine.
Turning Morty into summers
Kuro go And it also turns out
she's never seen Total Recall before
because everybody at the party
but her knows what Cueto is Morty saying Open
your mind is also a reference to what Cueto used to say
during the Total Recall movie.
In the movie, he could actually speak normally,
but in the context of the episode.
Morty
in all the other Kuatos can only say open your mind,
even though they're trying to say four sentences.
back at
home, Rick's watching more interdimensional cable.
The kegger fake show is a parody of
Is This Cake, which went crazy on social media
a couple of years ago
with people creating cakes that look so lifelike
nobody could tell whether or not
something was cake or not.
even though they implied this contestant
is going to kill the other one because he's screaming
that he's real.
Rick later reveals that they're sentient cakes on
the show that always keep you guessing, quote unquote.
So sometimes the people screaming that they're not cake
are still
just cakes.
the one of the other funny things, too,
is that there's so much interdimensional cable
that you find them watching randomly
in different episodes, but they haven't done
an actual interdimensional cable three episode.
In fact, back during season three,
when they started doing Morty's Mind Blowers,
that was like the episode that they did instead of
doing interdimensional cable three
Since then, we've had a number of seasons
in a number of more Morty's Mind Blowers parodies,
Rick breaks the fourth wall again
when he says he thought the slider thing
was going to be the whole thing this week.
that's him referencing that he knows he's
a fictional character inside a TV show.
He also does it later in the episode to Summer does
more chores from the tour wheel to get Rick's help.
This time she's on the level with the plant
based creatures she uses her social media
to get the targeted ad learning about the Kuato club,
which winds up being a bit of a meta joke.
So part of the joke here is that her
phone was listening to her when it was in her pocket.
Like even when her phone was off,
it was listening to her.
it hurt her talking about her
Kuato Everybody making fun of her.
CUETO And that's how it knew
to give her a quote to add on her Instagram
any of those was meant to be a funny bit
in the context of the episode.
In real life, that is a real thing.
Your phone or some apps on your phone
can use your microphone even when your phone's
in your pocket to listen to what you're saying
and give you targeted ads based on that.
so, even if you haven't visited any websites
or made any kind of searches based on any terms,
even if you just talked about it, then suddenly
you get an ad for the thing that you just talked about.
That's why Now everybody's going to be super paranoid
about the stuff they talk about near their phones.
the other joke here, too, is that the ad really
was predatory
because the club was the one that hosted Kenneth
in all the people that would just steal photos
in harvest them and sell them on the black market.
because later as they reveal at the club
in the private VIP room, everybody in the VIP room
were people who bought Calvados on the black market
and then had them attached to their bodies.
So, like, literally
everybody here is part of that evil black market ring.
they probably created that predatory
ad looking for other codes to harvest.
Now, every time somebody gets an ad on Instagram,
they're going to think twice about what
it's actually trying to sell them.
Tricia also posts a meme based on a real life meme,
how it started and how it's going.
You see that all the time, all over social media.
some are takes a space cab to the other planet
where the club is and meets the other girl then
who gets captured she ends up saving in then gets with
at the end of the episode reminding you that she's bi.
I think she's gotten with other girls on the show
before or she's referenced doing that in the past.
Generally, summer is meant to be like
the horniest character on the show next to Rick.
they said it the whole bit here
where everybody at the club can somehow understand what
those are really trying to say,
even though they only verbalize it as open your mind.
when quiet picks up summer, they have a bit of a joke
about them hooking up while they're Kuatos hook up
So for a brief second, you think that they're going
to have like a four way hookup
When they go to the private room at the club, zoom
in enhanced behind them.
Here this koto. Seems like it's a frozen upside down.
But remember, everybody at the club here
bought their quarters on the black market,
so it probably got attached in the wrong position
upside down when they bought this koto.
that's also probably why none of these shadows
wind up speaking and they all look
so depressed,
like all the commandos look really depressed
because they were stolen from other people
He also seems here
like he understands that they're in danger
maybe because of his enhanced psychic powers
but some are hasn't learned to decode what he says yet
and doesn't pick up until it's too late.
They introduced the main villain, Kenneth,
who has quite those inside Kratos.
Let me know if you think he's a parody
of a specific celebrity.
He does have a weird Jesus haircut Summer reminds
you of how DTF she is, how horny she is
when the first thing she gets upset about
is thinking that Kenneth has a girlfriend
so they won't be able to hook up.
I also love how deep they go on this whole koto joke.
Like they put a tiny quarto bag over Morty's head.
you to see the writers working on this episode.
Like, how far can we take this koto joke?
how about Kuatos inside, Kuatos, inside
other Kuatos.
they finally pay off.
Summer's Inspector gadget ponytail upgrades
picking the lock in the unlocking
sequence is her admitting
that she doesn't appreciate Rick enough Later.
Rick also reveals it as other secret abilities,
killing some of the thugs.
then when Beth tries to wake Rick up to get his help,
they remind you about some of his own personal defenses
and inspector gadget upgrades.
Like if she tried to touch him normally,
she would have gotten her hand blown off.
I'm assuming he turned some of them on
and some of them off at times,
because he also has special defenses
that literally kill you if you come too close to him
when he goes looking for summer,
he goes to the vending machine room.
You see Summers goes goggles that he reference earlier.
There's a copy of Thor's Hammer
from the Marvel Universe.
The there's a green magneto helmet.
I'm not sure what the other devices are, so you can
let me know what you think they are in the comments.
The visor also might be a cyclops helmet too
that shoots a beam
The idea is that Rick will create
whatever Morty or Summer asks for,
and he'll put it in the vending machine
when he goes to the morty's mind
blower's room, they do a close up
on a bunch of the vials, zoom in, enhance.
There's a pocket poo one.
There's one that says time, one that says balls.
There's a Stanford one.
There's a reference to Stanford Pines
from Gravity Falls in the crossovers
they've done on the show if it wasn't clear
Gravity Falls is cannon to Rick and Morty.
They've been having crossover moments like this
since season one.
there are also a couple of moments on Gravity Falls
that could be looked at as Rick and Morty Easter eggs.
Do all of the creators of both shows
are also personal friends in real life,
which is why a lot of those references
crept up a couple of years ago,
I did a much bigger video on all the Rick and Morty
Gravity Falls crossover scene, so I'll link it
below the description because it is pretty cool.
They're bunch more villains though.
Like this one says virginity.
I don't know whose virginity it is.
This one says micro tit in this one just says lol.
inside the garage.
The A.I.
makes a joke about doing things for dramatic effect
like black and white.
It also references
the fact that his voice is based on Rick's
dead wife when he says
he doesn't like doing things for dramatic effect,
when in fact, that's the whole reason
why her voice sounds like his dead wife's voice.
they make a bunch of Liam Neeson taken references
when they put Morty
on the black market house where they prep them
to be attached to the highest bidder.
they continue the take references with Rick
going for Liam Neeson,
just going around beating people up,
looking for information.
The whole bit about the commandos giving them
special psychic powers is also from Total Recall.
But the way they visualize
some are talking to Morty inside their minds.
Space is based on stranger things.
When 11 is using her powers it, inside their minds.
Summer can hear Morty's normal full sentences
because he's not verbalizing it,
the whole bit about the black market
selling the shadows is sort of a combination
reference to the taken movie and the Squid game series.
some are makes another froth frisbee golf joke
when she throws the laptop at the woman like a frisbee
and Rick breaks the fourth wall again
when he says he rescues Morty at least seven times
per season,
another reference to them living in a fake TV show.
they continue the Inspector Gadget references
when Rick reveals he has a giant inflatable butt.
there was actually a big reveal here
in this part of the episode.
Rick reveals
the reason why he's so much harder on summer.
Like making her do
the tour wheel is because he respects or more
does treats her like an equal,
and she reminds him of his dead wife,
meaning that Diane's personality was a little bit
more like this, which explains a lot.
Also remember at the end of episode
five after they killed Rick, Prime Evil Morty revealed
the only member of the family
that he was actually afraid of was Summer.
So they're trying to say
the summer is like a secret bad ass on the show.
I think part of the idea too, is that she just
does not give an F like she is totally unhinged.
So she doesn't have limits
the way that Morty has limits.
I think the other even funnier part here, too,
when he's talking about summer
being like his dead
wife is saying that he treats Morty more like a dog
then they sort the whole bit with Ken is shadows
inside Kratos in when summer gets confused later.
She was actually correct in saying
that it would have been the fourth Cueto
if that last one had survived
and they hadn't dumped it back in the ocean.
Like he kept saying, No, wait,
I have one more thing to reveal.
Like there was going to be another fourth Cueto
inside that third Cueto, one of the other differences
here, too, during their fight
is they revealed the second Cueto could speak normally.
Unlike all the other shadows,
they can only say open your mind.
they're really epic fight scene
also turns into a parody of the they live longer
fight sequence with Roddy Roddy
Piper versus Keith David
reminder to the key David also voices the U.S.
president on Rick and Morty.
like I said, they try to take the Kyoto joke
as far as they possibly can.
Logically, in the second, Kyoto whips out a knife.
no idea where he got that knife.
But the knife itself
also has a smaller Kuro knife inside the blade.
they said that the missiles bit that they use later
in the episode at the Frisbee golf game.
And Rick makes a motion smoothing joke
when they're trying to get the spider harness back.
Motion smoothing is usually a reference
to people putting motion
smoothing or taking it off the settings in their TVs.
without getting too into the weeds about TV's settings
and what motion smoothing is, generally
it makes things worse, like give all your TV
shows, your movies, this weird soap opera effect.
So if you can turn off motion smoothing on your TVs,
then they pay off the whole bit with quite a morty
spider harness like he stays is Kuro Morty in?
Doesn't have Rick fix him, make him big again.
and they pay off him trying to get super popular
because it makes him super good at Frisbee golf
until he gets clowned on again for accidentally
almost blowing everyone up with the missiles.
summer guest with that girl that she's saved.
And then during the post-credits scene,
they pay off the whole bit about the squid game
parody in the black market.
Take in reference all the rich buyers
here are waiting to get their photos or already
have them from the taken house.
There are masks, all this stuff,
this room, everything is based on the squid game series
in apparently they get super pissed off
when this other guy messes up their whole 69
bit, like he makes the wrong kind of reference like,
how dare you?
there are a whole bunch of Easter ggs and references.
So if you spotted any during the episode
that I didn't talk about during the video,
just write them below in the comments
in my full episode video we'll post next week.
there's a whole bunch of big stuff coming up,
so everyone click here for my Invincible Season
two Episode four video and then click here
for all my other Rick and Morty episodes.
Thank you so much for watching.
Everyone stay safe
and I'll see you guys in the next one!